you know not zero nuts to me at least
feels like a more faithful reimagining
of ex-con maybe not a reimagining it's
just it feels more like a straight-up
remake with a graphical overhaul so if
you're a fan of the Firaxis version of
XCOM you might finds you know it's a
little bit more difficult at least at
first there's a good quick dog guide
that comes with it which will basically
give me an outline of how to live for
the first two months and that was pretty
helpful for me even as even else like a
season
XCOM player and for exhibition you have
the one base and you build everything in
that one base whereas in see no nuts you
you place your bases individually
wherever in any region you put in you
put them anywhere on the map and that
really just means you're you're in that
region so you can defend that region you
put put radars in your base like the
original XCOM and that extends your
you're sort of the basis visibility on
what what your foes they can see and
what intermissions they can take on
you know the Firaxis remake it was like
a move shoot that's kind of all you did
yet two action points basically and
that's all you get whereas in Z no knots
and the original XCOM you get a number
of action points like say 70 or 60 and
every action you take costs some happen
point so you can say you can move shoot
move shoot it should move shoot move so
there's just a bigger palette of things
you can do xeno nuts you know in a trunk
when it comes to tactical fighting
there's on any proper classes so to
speak it's all based on the stats of
your character so if he has high
accuracy you're going to want to make
from the sniper if he has a high reflex
rate you're gonna want to make him the
assault guy and just just the warning
like this game is difficult like you're
not gonna finish this game on your one
playthrough you will probably have to
restart this game once or twice a to you
I'm on my fifth restart personally
because I screwed up a bunch let's just
say that so there are a couple of small
things that they've changed from the
original
XCOM in zero nods but what most most
what I know is that they changed was a
lot of the minutiae has been gotten rid
of like for like my favorite example for
that is in the original XCOM you had to
buy magazines for all the guns you have
to buy all your spare magazines or
create them yourselves whereas in Z no
nuts you have to make the guns I think
if you enjoyed
XCOM enemy Unknown the Firaxis version
and you're looking for more of that
tactical combat fighting aliens vibe
then xenoliths is definitely a game you
should at least truck